bonsoir bonsoir très très content de
votre choix cette semaine bobby bazini
on s'est ennuyé ça fait quoi ça fait
quatre cinq ans et je me suis dit je
suis certaine que patrice doit aimer
parce qu'il a tant aimée paolo nutini
taper dans les mains corps je vous
l'utilisez j'aime polynésie jeune bobby
bazini son discours écoutez j'ai coûté
des milliards de fois des milliards vous
avez tous le dixième des milliards de
fois maudit bazini ont leur place
originaire de mont-laurier 25 ans
seulement deuxième album extrêmement et
cette voix qui viennent d'ailleurs
donc pour moi l'effet de surprise s'est
estompée un peu mais quand même toujours
étonnant de voir que celle-ci vieille
voie vient d'un si jeune corps par
contre je dirais que la voie est plus et
plus travailler j'ai l'impression c'est
lui qui écrit ses textes compose la
musique que j'ai l'impression qu'il
incarne un petit peu plus ce qu'il
chante sa ressource de génie je trouve
un autre album beaucoup mais oui mais on
reste mes mails en fait c'est la
question que je me pose est ce que moby
bazini peut faire quelque chose moderne
de résolument moderne on verra pour la
suite
des fois c'est sur cet album ça passe ou
ça casse elle prendra bien violent oui
mais c'est parce que c'est une petite up
connais bien c'est un puriste
je sais pas si vous savez mais vraiment
croisade contre les disques compacts lui
ce qu'il veut c'est rendre accessibles
au grand public
les enregistrements de qualité
supérieure alors il a lancé en début
d'année pour nos son service de
téléchargement de musique de haute
résolution
il comptait céder et d'essayer de faire
cet album chez jack white des white
stripes anciennement à nashville dans ce
qu'on appelle un beau et chaud bref
c'est une cabine d'enregistrement des
années 40
alors il rentrer là dedans et
s'enregistre directement sur vinyle
alors on est vraiment dans le gars qui
veut faire une déclaration ici sur le
budget ouais bon ben on sait ce que ça
donne
jean lorrain
ouais
je mens
questionne
moi c'est ce à quoi j'aime beaucoup
beaucoup peut-être de sa démarche
ben je veux pas être convaincu que ça
lui appartient à une curiosité mais
j'aime savoir
on se laisse avec mara tremblay en fin
de rallye dont elle aussi le 7 octobre
prochain un nouvel album de marathon et
même si ça doit faire car je n'ai pas
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup sont beaux
yeux ok aurait-il plus on se laisse le
tabac
ça
je